common he is on a mission to reimagine
the nation's criminal justice system
about 96 percent of incarcerated people
in this country have a chance of
returning to their communities someday
and common says they should come home as
better people erika duncan recently met
at with a stateville correctional center
that's a maximum security prison in
common's home state of illinois
every
time i visited people incarcerated they
said man
we just want people to know we're human
beings
we were with rapper and activist common
as he unveiled a music studio inside the
walls of this maximum security prison
just outside chicago one of the things
that has allowed me to fulfill my
purpose in life is music and i think
this can be such a a unifying factor for
people who are incarcerated and also an
expression of themselves where they get
to learn about themselves and feel
empowered and feel like they are valued
funded by private donations and by
commons non-profit the music program is
aptly named a rebirth of sound
during the 12-week course groups of nine
inmates who had to apply to the program
will learn songwriting audio engineering
and music producing give your boy a
second chance if one of these inmates
makes a hit record
or goes viral a beat anything
what next i mean that is going to happen
i'm putting it out there first of all
i'd be overjoyed and it would be a
powerful way for us to hear
from them and connect with them now i'm
meant into the youth and
music transcends so many things
43 year old yarmel thomas sees music as
a way of collaborating with others and
connecting with his passion
he says he loves mozart and even studied
music and business marketing in college
before being incarcerated at the age of
26. you said sitting here is a full
circle moment moment for you yeah how so
because when i first
was transferred to stateville
this was receiving part of receiving and
i was in that cell right over your
shoulder in 229 and i was extremely
depressed and extremely suicidal
taken
a lot of cocktails of psych meds i
didn't talk to anybody now i'm sitting
here conversing with you i mean
god has transformed my life despite
never having a criminal record in 2004
thomas stabbed his ex-girlfriend to
death he was convicted of first degree
murder and armed robbery he's scheduled
to be released in 2070. do you feel
remorse absolutely there's not a day
that i don't think about her i didn't
realize that i had mental
health issues it was just i had a lot of
unresolved anger issues that i wasn't
aware that i had
these days thomas is working toward a
master's degree in restorative justice
and christian ministry he hopes to one
day be a counselor and says the music
program is just another positive outlet
music is therapeutic it allows you to
just release whatever frustration you
may have at that moment people judge us
based upon
that one bad terrible moment in our
lives a lot of us are no longer that
person you know there's a history of
critics when it comes to prisons and
they get to watch television they can go
back to school and get degrees they get
three square meals a day shelter
now they get music
you say what to those people you can't
just throw people away
i mean what
god didn't throw everybody makes
mistakes he didn't throw them away don't
throw us away just give us our
opportunity
it's time to try something different a
better day for you means a better day
for the staff here we're all in this
together warden dave gomez has worked in
the prison system for more than 30 years
he says programs like these develop
incentives for inmates and create a
safer environment for everyone other
programs have shown benefits if you take
a therapeutic community
like my previous assignment which was at
sheridan correctional center it was a
therapeutic environment focused on
substance abuse their recidivism rate
was 10 to 15 points better than the rest
of the states 10 to 15 points better yes
ma'am this time feeling i can't change
this so why not this we have to do
something different if you always do
what you always done you always get what
you always got i want you to express my
apology to my community
but for common what's always been done
he says amounts to an unjust system when
you hear people say well wait a minute
you know these are some of the toughest
criminals whether it's sexual assault
murder
why do they deserve to have music that's
a privilege
well
music is a gift for sure anything i say
in this song one of the things that like
scientists can tell you is that you know
when you're a young person
a lot of things that you do
your brain is not developed to make good
decisions in certain ways and it's no
excuse
it's no
justification but it's
an understanding
now how do we
correct things from this point and i
don't believe it should be a consistent
dehumanizing of that person and this
country this is a country of second
chances this is a country of opportunity
had an idea to put me in the booth
redemption redemption
this system is not serving those who are
incarcerated redemption should be
afforded healing should be afforded the
music is an opportunity to do that
the students in the music program could
get time off their sentence if they are
eligible but it's a small incentive the
real incentive here is the chance to
express their creativity and collaborate
and it's important to note the idea to
bring the music uh behind bars
originally came from a 31 year old
criminal defense attorney in chicago
named ari williams we did speak to as
well
but i think it's the idea these people
are human a lot of them will enter back
into society so what are we doing to
prepare them and allow them to
you know express themselves so that
they're more likely to the best so that
guy said you always do what you always
do you get what you always got we all
have to start rethinking the prison
system because it ain't working yeah
rehabilitation looks different for each
individual rehabilitation is the word
it's not a forever sentence rica thank
you very much